okay how's it going brahs let's try
again
some facade facade whatever you want to
call it with trip trip trip and grace
and my name will be um let's see if we
can do at the dog we haven't been a guy
Gonzalo
ah yes Gonzalo is coming over for visit
ghazzal oh I am I know where I am
oh I'm frankly here it's not gonna die
yes I'm here and I hear it's Wow
oh yeah ah yes it's very nice to see -
you see - yes where is the wine bet it
is oh here we are yes yes very good very
good
I'll just sit down here hello yes what
do you want hi how are you got it's been
a while just give me the wine okay woman
mm-hmm are you happy now Rui you look
wonderful
of course I am Gonzalo I was above
yourself at home okay uh I'm just gonna
go close the door
this phone is mine now No Salo seeing
you again makes me remember the
wonderful times will you ah man I
clicked wrong okay never got Vince hello
are you are you looking for something
yes more jewellery and stuff like that I
mean not nothing laughing yeah
okay anyway I forget what we were
talking about naked women of course so
Gonzalo uh oh I'll get it
No we have a guest week I get it she
pick it up what wait wait let's just
wait for the answering machine nah I get
it
don't ah stupid woman
where is it it's gums ah yes
yours boys Oh Gonzales okay no you're
talkative Gonzales what do you want
stop calling okay stop calling oh good
you hung up I can call him back later
yeah you brought down a few days bet
that well Grace's parents there's
something else really classical you know
they're impossible they expected it
sounded how secure to attend all their
stupid socialite charity benefits and
parties it's so tiresome I agree very
tiresome
well we're all friends here that's it
obvious sculpture I've ever seen a fix
us some dreams honest huh
what's the matter was first a sample
from my new set of him ah finally some
wine and luck yes Greta's mm everybody
tells me I fix the best drinks no you're
gonna love this
my god please let's not go overboard
with the drink preparation I want
something stronger
I think it where it just make us all
margaritas no something stronger I said
about something simple like a nice glass
of chardonnay
no okay okay okay Mar how the [ __ ] died
spaghetti that's my grad Jesus know what
why don't I just open up a bottle of
Merlot and make it easy we don't need to
forget this give me s you don't - the
fancy charts tonight grace I assume you
want your usual a lovely very cold glass
of chardonnay you know I don't want to
drink tonight I don't want anything ah
very nice
okay yes you can help me understand
where I went wrong with my new
decorating huh
disgrace give me the wine now how do we
go finally you know I chased these
little glass sculptures for god knows
how long now I always hear people
talking about them at our parties okay
just give me the one however I look at
them I suddenly get such a such a
headache
Oh grace
give me the wine no I mean man whatever
you are do you want the kiss what do you
want
give me the wine wine greatly seems no
not a problem with your decorating trip
that's what you always say but believe
me this room needs to be redone first
chance I get I'm going to return
whatever furniture they're willing to
take back okay just give her the wet
wrap Jesus Christ make giving me
headache so much friggin talking I'm so
sick of this
oh man I'm taking Stefano with you like
go to the heck out of it [ __ ] place I
hate you guys so much let's go Stefano
can I put you down huh then I'm gonna
open this door I don't want you maniac
you sick I'm not a section maniac you
guys are friggin crazy taking some mana
with you you're thinking of leaving
yes you guys suck ha ha ha ok this
Kosovo no I don't need them inside I'm
native and I'm gonna leave I just laugh
yourself what are you I'm late alright
wait is he going high go back you can't
throw me in to throw me out what the
[ __ ] are these loves apana I'm so stupid
a [ __ ] lab oh my god oh wow yeah I
don't think we'll get much further if
you want leave it like and favorite this
if you want more of a CAD I'm not sure
but we'll see I guess
I touched that Sam I want some why
fidgeting not right mine whine whine
whine whine whine whine I won't whine
now give me the mine give me wine no
woman